[Music]  it was smooth sailing at the convention  center today as hundreds of people  walked in to get their second  covid vaccine several people telling us  they had no issues today and were  in and out within minutes a big contrast  to those recent delays we told you about  as crews faced  battling a computer glitches there one  woman describes what it means for her to  get the second vaccine  and ending her pandemic nightmare  i will definitely keep wearing a mask  but i do intend  to see family once i've had  the second vaccination and the  additional time has passed  and my family members have it as well we  will definitely be getting together  and yes we're going to hug a hug  sounds good that was the same answer a  lot of people said as they  walked out of the convention center  pretty anxious to reunite with their  loved ones brian